[Musica]
buonasera
grazie a tutti è un enorme piacere per
me essere oggi con voi qui a taranto e
voglio ringraziare gli organizzatori di
questo ted in particolare francesco
giurì che potete vedere con me in questa
foto molto recente che abbiamo scattato
quando studiavamo il liceo scientifico
all'istituto salesiano don bosco qui in
viale virgilio a taranto dopo la
maturità scientifica a mi sono iscritto
ad economia all'università di bari con
la quale tuttora collaboro per un master
in digital marketing e nel 1997 mi sono
laureato discutendo una tesi di laurea
su internet non sapevo esattamente
quello che stavo facendo
ma sono riuscito a convincere il
relatore la commissione della bontà del
mio lavoro
quello che vedete è il capitolo 4 della
mia tesi di laurea che si intitola
teleshopping naturalmente parlavo di
quello che oggi tutti comunemente
conosciamo come ecommerce e da allora ha
letto di una piccola parentesi come
ufficiale della marina militare italiana
che da tarantino non mi potevo lasciare
sfuggire mi sono sempre occupato di
internet nel 1999 con un'azienda di bari
andammo al bari cento per convincere
pistolato a vendere uno stock di
accessori e profumi moda firmati su
internet lo facemmo con una tecnologia
asp ma non vendemmo nulla fu un
fallimento non è investito in maniera
sufficiente nel marketing ma
fortunatamente in quel periodo in italia
tutti i grossi gruppi investivano in
start up del mondo internet dunque io
vado a milano per sostenere nel 2000 per
sostenere un colloquio con il gruppo
fininvest per la startup gianpi e mi
ricordo che poco prima del colloquio
vada ad un bar in via vincenzo monti e
ordino 1 espressino ecco l'espressivo a
bari è quello che vedete qui in realtà
questo a milano si chiama marocchino
ragione per cui il barista mi servi un
caffè corto questa cosa mi fece
innervosire non poco ma ciononostante
superò il colloquio e dunque mi trovo
a milano a lavorare per la start up e
gianpi all'interno del gruppo fininvest
anche quella della verità non fu un
grosso successo anzi direi piuttosto un
fallimento considerando che fininvest e
non riuscì a quotare in borsa gianpi ma
io ebbi comunque l'opportunità di
lavorare per il gruppo mediaset nel
quale per oltre dieci anni
sempre nell'area digital e mi sono
occupato di servizi internet e in
particolare all'inizio gestivo servizi a
valore aggiunto di interazione
televisiva via sms per programmi ad
altissimo valore culturale come amici di
maria de filippi il grande fratello e
chi vuol essere milionario con il quale
gestivamo programmi di interazione e
televisiva via sms facendo accordi con
gli operatori telefonici
dopo nel 2007 steve jobs inventa
l'iphone e come ben sapete è tutto il
mercato e il mondo degli sms a pagamento
crolla io però riesco a convincere
mediaset a farmi sviluppare la pg come
24 per ios e poi quella di sportmediaset
il che mi vale una promozione
responsabile marketing e poi nel
nell'ultimo periodo mi occupo di
innovation per l'area digitale del
gruppo mediaset avendo l'opportunità di
viaggiare spesso in silicon valley e a
san francisco e come potete ben capire
per una persona che si è laureata con la
passione per internet trovarsi a san
francisco in quella che è considerata la
mecca mondiale dell'innovazione
ovviamente un passaggio molto importante
perché ti trovi proprio dove tutto sta
succedendo da quel punto di vista ma
questo è nulla a confronto di quello che
invece mi succede dal 2016 quando a
seguito di occhio colloqui per lo più
via skype o per telefono con cinesi o
europei in giro per il mondo
mi trovo a lavorare come responsabile
marketing e sviluppo di business per
l'ufficio italiano di alibaba alibaba
non tutti lo sanno in un'azienda che
nasce in c.da in una piccola cittadina
di nome angelo di 9 milioni di abitanti
nella provincia di zhejang in cina ed
alì babà non nasce in un garage in
silicon valley ma nell'appartamento di
questo signore jackman che assieme a 18
suoi amici fonda a quello che oggi è uno
dei gruppi
commerce se non il gruppo e commerce più
grosso al mondo con oltre 100 mila
dipendenti
quello che stiamo facendo e con
l'ufficio italiano è quello di
rappresentare come un'ambasciata a tutte
le attività del gruppo e soprattutto
quella di supportare le aziende italiane
esportare in cina e nel mondo
utilizzando le nostre piattaforme
questo è stato fatto nell'ambito di un
processo di internazionalizzazione che
inizia nel 2015 e che porta alibaba ad
aprire uffici in tutto il mondo
australia giappone corea india varie
città negli stati uniti e in europa fra
cui appunto quella di milano dove
abbiamo aperto gli gli uffici è molto
difficile lavorare per un'azienda cinese
i cinesi sono persone tuttora nonostante
internet e la globalizzazione diverse da
noi diverse per il modo di parlare per
il modo di pensare per la loro cultura e
non è facile interfacciarsi con loro
prendo in prestito questa slide da un
libro di infografiche pubblicato da jean
guy 1 e la quale è una cinese che va a
lavorare va a vivere in germania e dopo
di che scrive e pubblica questo libro di
infografica prendo questa ad esempio per
far vedere come un occidentale e in blu
fa per passare dal punto a e b e come
invece fanno in cina
e questo solo per farvi vedere una delle
tante differenze che si incontrano
lavorando con loro è sicuramente potete
immaginare la mia gioia in uno dei primi
giorni di lavoro quando continuava a
ricevere email indirizzate a me scritta
in cinese più o meno come questa che che
vedete vi assicuro che non è non è
facile però tutto questo mi ha permesso
di capire un poco meglio che cosa sta
succedendo in cina in termini di
innovazione ed in generale tenete
presente che la cina è un paese lontano
10 mila chilometri dal nostro e grande
30 volte l'italia è un paese che sta
vivendo veramente un boom molto
particolare
giusto per per darvi qualche dato sono
oltre 200 le città con più di un milione
di abitanti e in questo momento la cina
sta vivendo uno dei fenomeni di
urbanizzazione e più più grandi il più
grande della storia del dell'umanità e
sono tante anche le innovazioni che in
questo momento si stanno vedendo in cina
che è cambiata molto negli ultimi anni e
soprattutto molto velocemente e questa
innovazione questo boom riguarda un
miliardo e 400 milioni di persone il 60
per cento delle quali sono connesse a
internet tenete presente che il 60 per
cento di 1,4 miliardi sono 829 milioni
giusto per darvi un un paragone la
popolazione intera degli stati uniti è
fatta da 350 milioni di persone
se guardiamo all'europa sono se oltre
700 milioni ma non 829 che sono solo i
cinesi che in questo momento sono
collegati ad internet e sono collegati
ad internet per lo più con lo smartphone
nel senso che il cinese ha saltato a piè
pari la connessione ad internet con il
computer e utilizza internet
sostanzialmente per la stragrande
maggioranza tramite il cellulare è
l'internet cinese è totalmente diverso
da quello che noi siamo abituati a
conoscere
non sto qui a parlare dei motivi e del
per come e del perché in cina esiste un
internet diverso ma è un dato di fatto
che non esiste e google come motore di
ricerca perché in cina si usa baido non
esiste whatsapp o facebook per l'instant
messaging e social network ma c'è
un'unica applicazione wii chat del
gruppo stand cent a che serve a fare
tutto questo e molto di più
non esiste youtube ma abbiamo youku non
esisto e twitter ma i cinesi usano wabho
è il principale applicazione di
ecommerce e tau bavo con oltre il 60 per
cento di penetrazione del mercato be too
see in cina che permette a quasi 700
milioni di cinesi di acquistare prodotti
dal cellulare di qualsiasi categoria
merceologica
ma non vorrei solo porre l'attenzione
sul fatto che l'internet cinese è
diverso da quello del resto del
ma soprattutto il fatto che pur essendo
l'internet presento in un unico paese ha
un peso specifico molto molto importante
e giusto per farvi un esempio c'è è
stata di recente pubblicata una ricerca
di emarketer che dice che come il
mercato e commerce cinese sia il primo
al mondo
il secondo è quello degli stati uniti e
vale un terzo delle commerce in cina
questo per avere idea di quanto
importante quanto rilevante sia questo
mondo in termini di internet e di
innovazione è un'altra delle cose che mi
colpiscono sempre ogni volta che vado in
cina e la loro il loro utilizzo ormai
massivo del mobile payment ovvero la
possibilità di pagare presso casse tassi
supermercati sostanzialmente ovunque
anche per micropagamenti con le
applicazioni e le principali sono a
livelli al gruppo alibaba e which are
the del gruppo the scent che sono le
applicazioni che vengono utilizzati da
circa 900 milioni di cinesi per pagare
qualsiasi cosa per fare anche molto di
più fino a chiedere per esempio
microprestiti oppure pagare alla alla
romana e devo dire che io le prima volta
che andavo in cina cambiavo prima di
partire i soldi in italia mi procuravo
liyuan e non vi nego che mi sentivo un
po arretrato quando in coda alla cassa
io ho pagato con il contante quando
chiunque prima e dopo di me pagava
soprattutto nelle grosse città con il
cellulare indipendentemente dal ceto
sociale o dall'età della persona che in
quel momento stava pagando io è un'altra
cosa molto interessante secondo me
riguarda il fatto che la cina è stato il
primo paese al mondo ad inventare le
banconote nell'ottocento dopo cristo e
c'è chi dice che probabilmente sarà il
primo paese ad abbandonare
come potete vedere da questa notizia
pubblicata un mese fa il numero degli
unicorni cinesi è nettamente superiore
per la prima volta a quello degli stati
uniti non mi sono fumato qualcosa e non
vi sto parlando di una una creatura
mitologica ma semplicemente vi sto
parlando delle start up con una
valutazione soprattutto soap superiore
ad 1 miliardo di dollari
tenete presente che il numero di start
up pre presenti in un paese ovviamente
un indice dell'innovazione di quel paese
e stesso vale se andiamo a guardare a
questa a questa slide e la cui fonte
crunchbase dove dice che nel 2018
gli investimenti di venture capital in
cina sono stati superiori di quelli
negli stati uniti e lo stesso vale per
la ricerca in intelligenza artificiale
anche in questo ambito e questo è un
articolo di wired la cina sembra
seriamente intenzionata ad essere più
innovativa anche nell'ambito
dell'intelligenza artificiale sia nei
confronti degli stati uniti che degli
altri paesi al mondo
ultimamente inoltre avrete sicuramente
sentito parlare di tik tok è
un'applicazione che sta esplodendo
adesso in occidente bene a me non
risulta che ci sia mai stata un app
occidentale che si è riuscita a
svilupparsi ea diffondersi in cina ma
sicuramente tik tok può essere il primo
esempio di applicazione cinese che
invece si sta sviluppando in occidente
almeno a giudicare da questa sera e dove
si può vedere come a settembre tik tok
che è un'applicazione appunto lanciata
da un'azienda cinese da una startup
cinese sia in testa alle classifiche di
download tanto dell'app store e quanto
di android insomma quello che vi voglio
dire che probabilmente stiamo vivendo
una un sorpasso stiamo osservando quello
che probabilmente sarà un sorpasso
epocale in termini di innovazione da
parte della cina ai danni degli stati
uniti
io non ho un messaggio particolare da
lasciarvi alla fine del mio ted talk
però e non voglio nemmeno convincervi
non so ad andare in cina a studiare
cinese o a dirvi che verremo conquistati
dalla dalla cina sicuramente sono tanti
anche gli aspetti negativi legati alla
cina e gli stati uniti di cui io non ho
parlato nel mio team toth ma l'unica
cosa che vi posso dire è sicuramente di
provare a cambiare nel momento in cui ci
troviamo davanti a difficoltà che siano
difficoltà piccola come quella di di
ordinare un marocchino e vedersi servite
a qualcosa di diversa piuttosto che
ricevere una mail di questo tipo non
spaventiamoci di fronte alle differenze
ma invece affrontiamoli perché
probabilmente è l'unico modo per poter
accedere a ulteriore innovazione
comunque a riuscire a scoprire di più su
quella che sono
ciò che vogliamo fare o magari a
coltivare le nostre passioni
grazie